big shout out to hellofresh with
hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
go to hellofresh.com fury16 and use code
fury16 for up to 16 free meals and three
free gifts
what's up everybody welcome back to
another episode of wrists of fury i'm
kelsey cook we're here at the zodiac
studios at the moon tower comedy
festival in austin and today i am so
excited to have on two incredible guests
one who has been on before all right
returning guests i mean that's all right
that's a rude way to introduce again i
feel great going into it you know what
jay i'm sorry i brought you into this
yeah i can already see it's gonna be
very painful i didn't know i was part of
your revenge scheme you are you've
always been i thought
i thought you just wanted to hang
no this is deeper than that oh
some blood on the table so i have on dan
soder and big j ogresson yay bonfire
boys bonfire
boys yes you guys are both incredible
comedians and you have a serious xm show
together yes called the bonfire do you
like this set it's very cool i do it's
hilarious you brought your own trophies
from home yeah lousy with second place
trophies i've noticed that
dude had trouble with closing this is
this this is the silver medal studios
welcome to
runner-up productions oh so when dan
came on it was i was drugged
i was lied to i was told money was going
to be exchanged it never was you told me
you were paid to take a dive i was
she had me go down for the second game
yeah late in the game she reached in
she'll take it down 30 to 10k
go down i'll make you look good
and you two are you're [ __ ] best so i
played in uh oven mitts
yes beat you and when you lost we made
you dress yeah she probably never meant
to beat me
damn i scored a goal though you did
score a goal two goals mm-hmm
all right when dan lost he had to wear a
santa outfit and then drink a shot of
sriracha milk because it was because we
were making fun of the fact that he
drinks milk as a grown adult man
so
still does i know will not stop
unabashedly we'll drink it with
savory dinners yikes
lasagna and milk oh my god
what a psychopath that's a basket of
bread soon you got crush a pack of
cookies with an iced tea none of it
makes sense to me i'll live off the grid
dude none of you guys will ever happen
on your table also you with your guys's
bird bones sitting over here talking to
me like i'm not filled with calcium
that's true but if you ever get into a
yeah a car wreck i'll walk out of it
you're very cute
this guy must drink two percent no i
mean the skin's gone but you're going to
come out full skeleton fine
my mouths are fine but everything else
hurts uh milk i don't want anything
because that's what the video is about
this is a foosball show i don't want to
get it we're a team we're going to talk
dairy all day
i did not know what we were going to
uncover get into that milk
you guys just need to relax off it
passionately you guys are drinking that
oat milk and [ __ ] nut milk
i haven't had cow's milk in years yeah i
know and i can tell
you're not vibrant we have to actually
play foosball oh yeah yeah we'll only
talk about milk for 45 minutes all right
guys let's get into one
you better not get an injury on this
with all that milk in your body yeah
what is your football experience jay
um i said there's times i think in
nursing homes i've either broken into to
go to the game room or nursing home i
was in the sea family i walked by and i
would and i would do this
and that's it and that's it okay yeah i
don't think i've ever even seen anybody
play it wow okay is there a strategy for
who's gonna be forward who's gonna be
goalie
i'm gonna be dan said he's comfortable
at goalie okay so i that confidence
alone was enough for me great well and
then uh i don't care to give any more of
our game plan away but
i feel comfortable playing goalie okay
here's our first five plays
yeah this is what we're running skip
right 32 kick
so
[Music]
so we're gonna play a game to five first
round we're just going to play one game
let you guys kind of get warmed up
okay we'll chat if you get time
i wish so much that i was actually great
i know that's right this is the one is
this right and i'm just like nailing
like bank
shots this is the music montage where
it's like everybody dance now
and it's like starting to sheller yeah
we're having fun i don't know i guess
it's beginners look in reality you're
going to see some oven mitts
in reality we're about to this is going
to be rough i've done this before i
don't know because i've never played i
just have confidence that i'm like maybe
i'll be a natural
wow do you think that there's any chance
you'll beat me today
you know i've never played guitar either
let me see if i could do hotel
california real quick
if that works out i feel much more
confident about this you guys don't know
are there vegas odds on this i could do
the solo for master of puppets
it's 18 minutes but i mean it shreds
what's the action on those strings is it
gonna hold up we'll do it after
okay are you guys ready i'll just do
this i think all
you right eat that through
dan this is this is your moment
god hang on there we are
oh man it hurts when it happens it like
hits the taint i remember that sound now
that's such a great sound oh all right
damn yeah
all right this doesn't make sense you
can do it hang on i'm gonna do this
stuff she did
you have a little dribble hang on here
there you go i'm just doing this oh i'm
just milking the cap oh no i lost it
hang on here we are
there's the good stuff
milking the cabbage
is almost a full court one
there it is there oh here oh oh hang on
oh this guy hey oh look at you look at
you go
so you guys how long has the bonfire
been going oh don't casual conversations
right now
what's that as a host stuffed
oh
this is part of my strategy and
part of the show well it's a it's a good
strategy we were both
fledgling in the business
i'm back
because you know fine years i don't give
a [ __ ] whatever man texas is the place
to fall off does it make sense that i
was wagging on my show that would be
such great press is it a weird thing to
say that i still don't feel like i've
played foosball yet no you haven't okay
is it weird that i just feel like uh you
know at basketball games in between the
play when the kids come on and they just
throw
yeah yeah that's how i feel right now
like you're throwing two handers like
this yeah
in my mind i'm doing things but it's how
are you feeling up there do you want to
move back here
maybe maybe let's get shanked one more
time let me show you three three nil
what do you guys call two two zero oh
it's two zero yeah we'll get one more
okay jump in ready okay because i think
milk in the cow has worked a couple
times she's been upset by it no he's
milking the cow milking the cow
there he is okay
see with the moving defense kelsey this
is something i just invented
the effectiveness i really wanted to
make that right as you were mansplaining
baseball to me now i know with all those
recipes oh stuff you can't get to think
about other stuff like economics right
you know what that would be like it
really does just it hits you right in
the tank right every time anyway you
want to back up that's what sports is
about yeah
so anywho little lady
oh my god really the text is shining
through yeah all right all right
seems like this is the move that's what
i was doing dude but just wait uh-huh sh
she will
score you think so all right
that way
my pele
make sure you keep their legs down i've
learned that you know
that's important
just watching it it's very mesmerizing
i handled it yeah you did dude good
corner block can i make up terms for
foosball corner block beautiful great
corner block dude oh god i just handed
it to her that's a sh she's the play oh
all right see you did you already see
what i mean it like vibrates through the
handle that's weird yeah
that was a good play though dude
someone paid close attention to foosball
in my entire life even the way i say
foosball first of all dude this is where
the hustle starts
ready yeah time to turn it off
no here we go
if we make our moves more like [ __ ]
yeah but serious
it's like yeah get me from out there you
wish you know those kids in elementary
school have swung their backpacks and
fights and sometimes it connected that's
what we got to do
ready
ready for what us oh
oh i know you got it
huh
oh stuff oh
oh you know what i love with a glass of
milk some stuffed manicotti oh
it is italian dishes are great for milk
yeah what is up with you in the italian
milk
it's a good combo that gets [ __ ] on a
lot and i feel like it's unfair
that's mean she's like tapping the ball
oh what
[ __ ] that dude what is that now we play
5.0 you feel good about yourself i heard
you on your period so
we don't want to piss you off
i heard you someone said something mean
about it you heard about it and you're
upset so heard you got dumped and that's
not cool yeah so you feel better yet
whatever
[Music]
come over here we're going to do some
handicaps for this oh we're going to
look at your truck trying to make it
easier for you guys to beat me dan gets
to hit you with the trophy yeah over the
back of the head women's car
yeah
was this really a team you were on
well
yeah so i'll be playing
with my mom and stuff yeah really that's
pretty awesome yeah is your mom who got
you into it yeah she's in the foosball
hall of fame
really yeah so this is town that's true
okay so i grabbed you're a manning
you're like a man we all picked one so
just one of you guys yeah go ahead as a
team as a as a couple
what do you guys have one pink balls
just like horrible
just like our balls are pink
take a picture
what a great photo that looked really
sincere um okay so you guys are gonna do
i play foosball
does it play me
you guys are gonna start with two points
i
am gonna have we've never done this
before i'm gonna play with my hands
wrapped in cling wrap like barbie hands
oh wow we brought that here oh great
three so you're gonna start with two
points though oops sorry two so we have
um all right i get it
i'm not mending over this shot you want
yeah damn animals
thank you like these shorts are too
short and people are gonna see my
[ __ ] if i bend over um okay so
yeah you guys head over there you're
gonna get two points to start which one
front or back big shout out to hello
fresh with hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy fun and affordable that's why it's
america's number one meal kit i've
actually been using hellofresh for years
they're amazing i travel a ton so
getting a box of food right at my
doorstep is so helpful and the food is
insanely good i cannot recommend them
enough and the holidays can be hectic
obviously so hello fresh can help the
recipes cut back on meal prep and clean
up you can spend less time in the
kitchen and more quality time with your
friends and family hello fresh market
has your seasonal entertaining covered
with options like holiday cheese and
charcuterie boards and skinny dipped
dark chocolate peppermint almonds
hellofresh offers 50 menu and market
items to choose from every week
including vegetarian calorie smart and
gourmet options so you've got plenty of
variety the new year is a great time to
focus on what is most important to you
whether it's saving money by ordering
less takeout learning to cook or
prioritizing your wellness hellofresh
cuts back on time in the kitchen so you
can spend it on other resolutions with
meals ready in around 30 minutes or less
plus my favorite which are the quick and
easy meals including 20 minute recipes
and low prep and easy clean up options
so you can have food coming to you even
faster than you did before hellofresh is
actually 72 cheaper than a restaurant
meal of the same quality and you can
save on average over 65 dollars per
month when you order hellofresh instead
of grocery shopping that's more money to
put toward those other goals of yours in
2022. hellofresh offers the flexibility
you need to easily customize your order
online or in the app i love how easy it
is to change your delivery being on the
road sometimes i need to skip a week and
it's no problem it doesn't change
anything in my schedule it makes it so
much easier to get the food only when i
need it so go to hellofresh.com fury16
and use code fury 16 for up to 16 free
meals and three free gifts that's
hellofresh.com fury16 and use code
fury16 for up to 16 free meals and three
free gifts hellofresh america's number
one meal kit
i don't know if i trust this
this is uncomfortable which is good for
you guys hands are gonna get sweaty
they're gonna be disgusting you're gonna
be like deli meat when you pull that
thing off it's gonna be like damn sweats
i can't wait
okay so go ahead and take two points
what if we put on a tape
from like the 80s that was what got us
going
like iron eagle you like popped in a
table like something inspirational mind
if we rock with what we got going on
kicking some ass when you're trying your
best and the man's got a man so we have
two people two points as we play also um
we had samurel and taylor thomas on
earlier they were our first comedy
but that's what was discussed was like
you guys really are the true comedy
couple or the woke ones at least it's
much more impressive to like two guys
being a couple that's pretty cool
it's very 20-21 i don't know if you want
to push your heteronormative ways with
sami taylor or
look at your boys yeah we're out here
yeah we're paulie we're here we're queer
we're about to [ __ ] you up in this game
get ready
get ready with your leftover hands
[ __ ] blast it check this move out i just
learned
oh yeah i i got i saw some of this going
on
yeah i'll tell you what even in foosball
my left hand is just utterly useless i
can't even do the little jerk look at
that look at that control yeah this one
here it's all maybe put it like this
or maybe make it come on
yeah oh let's see how far we get up
we're already winning
[ __ ] disaster okay so i'm gonna ask
you guys questions that i asked sam and
taylor to see if you guys know each
other as well as you think bring it
better than them and if you can both
correctly answer you can get another
point let me jump the gun and tell you
right now he starts slow and ends fast
but one thing's for sure consistent
throughout romance yeah locked eyes
oh my gosh guys like a nurse shark
okay this cling wrap uh
we're gonna do our best at the club
you're busting
i don't know can you like just make that
more
wound
up
there you go okay well we're gonna get
this stripe so i'll be honest with you
you put that in the fridge no i'm not
keeping fresh yeah i don't trust those
sandwiches
okay
uh we're gonna start with an easy
question for you guys
uh dan what is jay's favorite movie
i'm gonna play as we do this roadhouse
son of a [ __ ] whoa that was were you
right i'm so upset you didn't know that
i know
i mean roadhouse is a good guess yeah
heat
heat yeah
heat's your favorite movie i mean we
both agree it's the greatest heist movie
of all time yeah
but
you know what
i feel bad man i feel really bad that i
didn't know that
you could see a dance favorite movie
though yeah this one
jacob quotes it a lot
so does no dj liu quotes it a lot
oh boogie nights yeah
well i can't give you the point for that
because you missed no no all right well
did sam and taylor get it right yes
well they're new they talk about that
[ __ ] all the time jay and i have been in
a long
glorious relationship
damn it um they're just hot to trot
because they're all on the netflix
flicks and [ __ ]
this is love
this
in the trenches you're doing real good
i'm not doing bad but i'm not doing good
for sure oh god oh
[Laughter]
no
all right we stopped
[Music]
that counts i don't know if that counts
we got the rule book here all right
that's 100 counts damn
all right i'm asking more questions i'm
gonna have to kill a homeless tonight to
reclaim my masculinity dude don't worry
about it dude i still love you i still
love you did sam say that about taylor
probably not okay when they lost um
jay what is dan's biggest pet peeve
[ __ ]
oh my hands are getting so sweet oh uh i
mean
i got a lot of them you do have a lot of
them a lot of peeves dude
oh god oh oh jesus oh god i set you up
oh god i set you up for failure so much
oh god
so do this do this wiggle thing oh
i can't turn my hand oh even with her
leftover hands this is still all off
that goalie cooking ah
dude don't worry goldie's [ __ ]
always cooking thank god
y'all failed me i'll find you [ __ ] up
okay you have a guest peeps hang on real
quick okay
guys
we are in hell yeah can we get a piece
of paper wrapped up look to your left
look to your right
foosball
is a game of inches now
i wish i had people i could call
all right let's go i'm too old
i can't do it for you
it's any given sunday for those of you
who don't know one of jay's
not favorite
all right do you have a guess for
biggest pet peeve oh god he did it again
almost
no guess for him
for biggest baby biggest pet peeve
pet peeve is um
no
you just it's me it's just mean what you
do
uh it's me and how you play foosball and
i hope you don't feel good about
yourself because it's very me
uh is that i'd probably go with that
right now yeah losing losing okay what's
his biggest pet peeve um
gossip
hot goss
guilty
just drives me back why do people got to
talk behind other people's backs why
can't they just be honest with each
other to hell with tmz let people live
oh
okay did sam and taylor get that one
they did they got i think they got all
of them honestly we haven't lost yet
yeah but their sex is more vanilla than
ours yeah i can guarantee that you guys
are doing crazy [ __ ] we're dirty um
we're dirty dirty dogs dude
that seems like it's tilted towards the
goal in the goal did that seem like that
to you yeah [ __ ] you kelsey yeah
all right okay
all right that may have been an
overreaction i'm sorry it was heat of
the moment [ __ ] i don't know i'm not
[ __ ] you i'm sorry i seem sweet you seem
sweet lovely very sincere i'm sorry i
kicked in your basement i didn't mean to
do it
oh my god it's just you come over here
with your wet hands no one zoom in on me
on my hands right now those things
yeah how are they it is you know what
clap real quick
it just
spritz comes off
let's go like that
yeah you can hear it oh i think you're
trying to figure out a solution for you
just want to confirm it yeah yeah yeah
no squeeze mashed potatoes now
i'm in some weird [ __ ] can you stomp
these slices zucchini
tootsies in there really sink those
piggies in there come on put your monkey
hands in it
can i ask you guys if you think you know
each other's favorite porn category
i mean
for sure and i know his yeah
he willing to share oh yeah dan's big
tits
his is a black eye gangbang
boom
on a girl on a girl
how's that did sam and taylor get that
one nope
oh god it's all connecting in my head
right now
i like my milk with a little chocolate
if you know what i mean
that was good what's my camera
where are we going b
you two really are a married couple this
is so fun to watch
[Music]
okay so we're gonna play the final round
this is called two ball down is familiar
yeah we each have a ball you say one two
three go you have to score both to get a
point if we each score one it's a wash
that makes sense oh yes okay okay
so
we were trying to figure out punishments
for you guys if you lose
we were going to have a gross food
challenge we still have gross food left
over from but you've got shows tonight
what's the gross food
well you can't now
do you think fish no
head cheese no what how much do i have
to ingest
like a bite
let's [ __ ] rock bring your [ __ ]
stupid food challenge i'll piss out my
butt for this
is that too much would you rather do
that it's gonna be hot feel like spicy
[ __ ] is the problem all right ready okay
we're gonna make it good um
it's to five right yep
i have to score both so yeah now if we
win do you eat the [ __ ] crystal but i
won't lose so it doesn't matter i don't
like that [ __ ] at all
hang on i wish there was like a piece of
equipment i could pull up my own i'm
like have you met bernice i bought my
own sticks
oh sorry i have knees
okay you ready one two three go
oh dude dude oh dan this is a panicky
moment for you you know what it is if
you're
full of ham oh my god this is fast
oh
this ball stuck
okay
she just hands it right back to us
oh jesus dude you're doing so good i'm
so proud of you
now one's in one's in work
one's in send it
[Laughter]
it's like getting in the water with a
shark
you're just swimming along having a good
time and they grab you
oh god
ah good day
do you keep stats cause i feel like you
know my blocks are not bad people have
been blocking me a fair amount today
okay well don't say it like everyone god
damn it
damn it you're saying it like everyone's
doing it and just kind of [ __ ] takes
out the
damn our dainty hands
i know these these weak city wrists she
got hands like baseball gloves
scary hand jobs screw yeah this girl
could take a hopper with no problem okay
one two three go
yeah dude that was can i just tell you
right now i just blocked that shot but
it was a
direct shot like
oh
yep
hang on though
this is my wendy's frosty freeze out
yeah oh
one two three go
oh
damn it i forgot you can bury him from
downtown too huh yeah yeah
we're moving we're dancing we're crazy
fun football playing
[ __ ] it had a spin on it go back to the
footage it's spun and then what gosh you
put a little bit of the schmutz on it
what kind of sorcery are you into some
sweaty [ __ ] man she keeps putting the
balls your grip is probably unbelievable
those algae hands you have now
lg hands oh my god okay one two three go
oh
if we make this noise she can't score oh
oh oh get it dude
rain down on her what's up sweet justice
rain down on us uh on the tyrant that is
kelsey oh yes
he's walked away from your guys
completely
i'm
what i was going to ask you guys earlier
you guys have die hard fans from the
bonfire what is the weirdest fan gift
you've ever received oh my god uh
what's yours when that
that couple that were both dressed like
rambo coming home oh my god and they uh
and they gave me a a framed picture of a
bunny and they said they named this
bunny after my daughter that's weird
whoa i took it home to make sure it
wasn't possessed and i threw it out okay
that i think that was the right move
yeah that's [ __ ] terrible they're
gonna leave in a hotel room it would
have created a haunting yeah i think the
i i know the fan and he's a great dude
and it's it's a cool gift but it was
so oddly personal that you're like man
you really know me he gave me a
t-shirt a long sleeve shirt of my mom's
high school
as a gift for her
oh or i was like yeah deep cut that's a
very deep cut shout out fresno high
school by the way go warriors i made you
a
good figure i made you a t-shirt of your
uh yes dude yes yes dude you i knew you
had it in you this whole time
god i'm starting to sweat just cause i
can feel the fire building in you
feel it dude you got the glow you've got
the glow she's nervous you can see it
we're okay
all right once the minnesota mustache
it's so scary
there you go
now i got the feel dude
legit puts movement on the ball
yeah all right quit tapping it you're
like a velociraptor cheater she made
some sort of a pack what's the
supernatural entity
i kept thinking about her deal with the
devil and that's why she's why she's so
good i hope foosball is worth a eternal
damnation
yeah have fun good for you have fun
hanging out with me
great so you have you embarrassed a
couple of dudes every once in a while at
a festival
hope that's worth internal damnation
good long time i don't think i don't
think you can be forgiven for that nope
one two three go i'd rather take blues
guitar playing you know what i mean
oh no no it's fine you're good no
here's the return
uh we wobbled her see see
she's not a machine
look at it they're cheering for us now
yeah
oh i've seen a lot of things here today
welcome welcome to the great wall
yes in the back
okay
just turn the butter who's gonna say
what is the
strategy here you know what the strategy
is
it's a blockade
strategy shut your [ __ ] down real quick
my strategy my dumbo your ass
swat you at the net uh nay uh
all right i'm starting to realize also i
have sweat rolling down the side of my
head those thoughts mean something i
know they mean i don't know it's all
devil's math
that's the devil's advocate yeah
the arithmetic the language of the devil
oh damn it chump you i feel like that
should be easier to score on and i think
i just keep timing it wrong every time
it's like the um mini golf windmill it's
on this rock get it messy
yeah dude line out oh
why can't i
oh what is happening
i'm not in the house of new tumble
get oh oh my god you're just humiliating
yourself at this point kelsey
i bet you can't even go to new
tournaments with you oh you'll be a fool
right now all those second place
trophies are oh god i did it again we're
almost back
oh man
man because hey kid
oh my god
hr
i legitimately need a napkin dude i'm
starting to cut these lights
it's not the lights dudes it's the
intense competition you know you get
that uh i'd be sweating too but i got
botox in my armpits
dried it right up
it comes out of my face
free advertisement for botox sponsored
okay ready one oh jesus i blew it one
two three go
there you go there you go
no
yes
listen it's like 21 at the casino it's a
push is a win
pushes away
pushes away pushes your win
that shouldn't have taken that long
well that's why you're second best most
players
right that's fine that's fair i guess
you got her
i do but i'm still secretly drinking
even though we're on camera
he sure showed her
yeah
oh anyways i was thinking about you guys
what's the smoking situation
is it cool if i rip one oh my god how do
you guys feel i mean embarrassed yeah
humiliated okay uh defeated
honestly though
well i thought i was getting the hang of
it at the end warming up yeah
so let's run it back
yeah who's the next cancel them yeah we
got it
all right guys so
um
dan you're gonna feed jay first so jay
put his blindfold on you're just gonna
try and guess what he's feeding me
you can still see through it so just try
to keep your eyes closed you can
taylor said you could
i can't see through i feel like taylor's
been lying to you and you've been
letting her just get away with it does
she have nuclear eyes
okay oh okay
okay i suggest putting
this just you know if it's black
licorice i'll throw up so i
i'm not a constitutional i can't just
give him that huh no that's not that's
not that's fun though
he'll know it too easily you got to mix
it up a little bit okay
dude don't worry
it's going to hit you with a little bit
bud
little dab will do me you know i love
you coat it up a little bit
oh
more than that well that's uh you could
serve that as an appetizer dan remember
recently i found it i was adopted so i
know
your real parents are so proud of you
are you ready dude i'm going right in
the chute just chomp it and gut it is it
a chew thing it's a light it's it's a
it's a pleasant it's a tender chew it's
a tender chew
and a [ __ ]
it's quite fruity
ready
open your mouth fruity wink
not very
sugary watermelon and
peanut butter no
warm but no
ketchup close
mayo close mustard yes
wow who knew that mustard could
transform like that with watermelon take
it off dude you just did it no no hold
on he's got more i do he's got more he's
gotta have one more thing well doesn't
dan eat some yeah then dan's gonna eat
something [ __ ]
all right you gotta give him one more
thing one more thing out here
can you slap me with a package or
something
dried apricots and rocks
here's some pebbles you [ __ ] idiot
okay give that a try oh all right here
you go dude
yeah
what are you doing
here they go
how are you feeling i'm gonna
aggressively swallow it and then tell me
what it is can you tell me why i'm doing
this yeah
it's not coming out it's not bad you're
good
get it in
it's completely edible and like fight it
in the parking lot or something cigar
ashes
[Laughter]
kale kale chip a ranch kale chip you
know what it was yeah we just lost them
in the sponsor because
he's like cigar
all right dude that was good you're done
wow okay you're done now we gotta
dan you get blindfolded and we gotta
switch out some of these
jay yeah i'm scared
i'm with you okay
thank you hang on you're safe i'm ready
to play foosball now
wow
so you can pick two of these three
individuals thanks
this reverse mask is so fun
let's just take big breaths
fire it in there dude
i would really like to see the face he
makes
yeah because i feel like it's going to
be that's going to be all right i mean
you guys are [ __ ] mean
is that fair little boy what
was a fork not a spoon consistency is
good this is going to be like a
consistency it's not a solid okay do it
open up
that's the faces i'm hoping for is that
yogurt
no
you have more guesses
describe what's happening in your mouth
it was like a pudding almost okay but
flavor-wise yeah but like uh
like a more of a dinner flavor
like a savory yeah like a savory
pudding say do they make chili pudding
do they make
what is it
it's uh it's prune
baby food oh my god dude babies get
pudding all the time
yeah everything's pudding oh that's why
oh man we gotta try this one i don't
know it's myself i'll even try this one
no let it loose no i'm saying i would
try this one this is bit all right some
more baby food see how it comes out a
big baby yeah it's gonna be a big big
boy my big big
i'm gonna put it on okay yeah
squeeze it in
those rats good roof i feel like he
should have to tip his head back
no
just hang on
and
there you go
oh sorry hit your chin
[Music]
it's intense
is it it's fruity you'll never guess
you'll never get it it's [ __ ]
strawberry jam paste
sort of what is it you can take your
mask off and look it's the smarty
squeeze yeah
does that make sense no yeah
oh my god
you guys weird problems i'm new
you guys were the absolute best that's
right i can't think of kicking the [ __ ]
out of us it's a blast um can you guys
plug anything you want big jcomedy.com
go there for live dates also at the
bonfire sxm on social media and twitter
danceoter.com for all his live dates uh
check those out and of course the
streaming app go get that you can also
listen to our podcast uh our radio show
as a podcast and then go get a serious
subscription and listen to the bonfire
jordy's gonna cut all that out
on faction talk 103.
103.
in the house um thank you for kicking
the [ __ ] out of us and feeding us yes
thank you for being on uh you can follow
me on instagram and tech talk at
kelseycuttcomedy you can get tour date
tickets at kelseycook.com and be sure to
subscribe to the all things comedy
youtube channel so you can see other
episodes you can watch dan's first
episode
he also lost yeah but i scored two goals
in that game
okay you can just take those those are
for you also we got her she admitted
it's
kicking the
door alabama alabama
we'll see you guys next time bye
[Music]
you